this is the arcade tutorial you've been
looking for in today's video we are
breaking down archicad 26 and i'm going
to teach you exactly how to use archicad
from start to finish in hopefully less
than 30 minutes what's going on guys my
name is david tomic i'm a registered
architect here in western australia and
today we are breaking down exactly how
to create this 3d model in archicad 26.
it's going to be relatively easy to
follow along so even if this is your
very first time using archicad beat
arcade 26 or any of the former archicad
products you are going to be able to
follow along here so let's turn around
to this brand new mac studio ultra and
get started with today's video welcome
back to our first archicad 26 tutorial
of the year with our very first log
cabin that we're going to be redesigning
it is basically a very simple square
with a roof and some cladding around it
however it does have all of the basic
architectural features that i'm able to
teach you in arcade 26 so you can master
this relatively quickly let's get
started with the usual and press control
or command 7 to open up our story
settings here we want to define how tall
our walls are and how tall each of our
stories are so first of all we want to
insert one below and we want to call
this our footings if i could spell that
would be much better so our footings are
always minus 172 millimeters
approximately for the ground floor our
first floor looking at this image is a
loft style design so what we actually
want to do is we want to probably keep
it about two seven four five two seven
four five is your typical timber framing
at two seven plus a forty five
millimeter plate at the top of the wall
to be able to structure our roof
now we don't have a first floor so in
this instance we can go ahead and click
delete story and we do have a roof in
play i'm going to leave the next story
height where it is and what i'm going to
do is unclick all of these elevation
markers on the side just because that's
personal preference later down the track
in your archicad journey now we can go
ahead and press ok and delete anything
that is coming up because we no longer
need it now coming across to the right
hand side of our screen we're going to
double click on the ground floor plan
and this is where we're going to start
what we see straight away is this is
lifted on a decking platform so we're
going to start by actually drawing the
outline of the house and then moving to
the subfloor in this instance typically
we'd start with the actual slab and then
move up but just to keep things simple
and understand everything as we go step
by step we are going to start with the
walls of the house so looking at the
walls it is a very simple box shape like
i said what we want to do is come up to
our wall tool up the top we then want to
make sure it is on our walls external
layout we want to make sure we're using
the outside face and that we're using
the correct wall composite i can see
that this is a cladded home so most
likely it is a timber frame home hence
again why we went for 2745 in our story
settings what we want to do is come down
all the way in our list till we find 19
millimeter insulated stud plasterboard
we want to select that wall material and
then we want to casually scroll across
the page so we aren't dealing with those
section elevation markers anywhere first
we want to click once and you're going
to see your wall automatically start
being created next we can tap the p
button on our keyboard p for peter to
flip that wall either way looking at it
it is a very very small house so what
i'm gonna do is hold shift and then
press the d button for david to actually
start typing in a distance i think the
length of this wall is somewhere about
eight to ten meters so i'm going to type
in 8 000 press ok
return hold shift again press d i think
it's probably about 4 meters to 5 meters
wide so let's start with 5 meters and if
we need to adjust we can furthermore we
want to come once again we want to do
another eight meters press okay and then
finish off our walls now you see we've
created three walls and not the fourth
because the fourth is obviously recessed
if i press escape and click on that wall
system you'll see it's all joined
because we created it as one wall system
next what i want to do is hold the
option button or the alt button
depending on what software you're on and
then create one more wall to join both
of these together pressing escape i can
now click on that bottom wall which is
individual from the rest of the walls
again clicking on the bottom wall
command or control d d for david
clicking once holding shift pressing d
again to dimension and typing in 2000 to
move our wall back to create exactly
what we see here in this image now more
than likely what is happening is this
wall here is not just one 90 mm stud
partition so once again we're going to
hold our option button click once across
i'm going to tap d for david type in 300
and double click at the top to basically
return and bulk out our wall frame now
so i don't have to repeat that exact
same process what i'm going to do is
click on that wall frame i've just
created command m for mirror find the
center of our wall and our house tap
option or alt to be able to actually
duplicate it hold shift and click again
now all of a sudden within a couple of
minutes we have the outside perimeter of
our entire design and if i highlight all
of those click command or control t to
open up our settings we're going to be
able to see that is linked to our roof
layer it is 2745 high
and our materials are as per the actual
wall composite if we want to go ahead
and adjust these we can simply click on
each of these overwrite them to what we
need and link them if we want them all
to be one specific material
now in this case we're not going to go
there just yet what i'm going to come
across do is go to our marquee tool at
the top i'm going to select our thicker
black line marquee so it selects
everything on all layers click once
right click
show marquee in 3d
double click your scroll wheel to
automatically jump to the actual model
that we've created and you'll see in 3d
in a matter of moments we've already
done quite a lot coming back to our
ground floor up the top and hitting
escape button we can continue working on
this project now that we know the
bounding boxes of the project i can
scroll out a little bit press command or
control down to go down one level right
click on my ground floor and click show
as trace reference now as i suggested
previously we go to our slab tool it
looks like this building is sitting
directly on the corners so if we click
once expand all the way to the edge of
our house we can then click on our slab
tool select one of the outside edges and
go to our offset edge
looking at this it looks like that
decking only goes one and a half meters
forward so we're going to type in 1.5
and again it looks like it goes 1.5
maybe 2 on the side so i'm simply just
going to press 1.5 on the side repeating
our marquee steps we can once again
quickly drag show marquee and we can see
what we've created we can see that our
slab is actually lower than it needs to
be so i can click on my slab once
command d
and lift it up once again
now if i wanted to i can go into this
settings go command t to open up all of
our settings i'm going to change it to a
generic shell i'm simply going to change
this to timber and then i'm going to
override all of my settings straight
away to provide a wood decking look now
i believe this is a wood oak look finish
so i'm simply going to click on wood
light oak press ok
click escape and there we go we have our
decking created in a matter of seconds
if we wanted to once again go command t
for tomich open up all of those settings
we could go wood again
and we could change that to whatever
wood we actually preferred let's say we
wanted a pine look instead there we go
we have a plane look very simple to
change all of your materials in archicad
26. now as you see we're starting to
have the shell of this building it's
coming along quite nicely so let's go
back to our right hand side click on
that ground floor
click the escape button if you're new to
architecture archicad or anything in the
field make sure you check out the links
down below
davidtomich.com.u has some amazing
downloads that are going to help you
design and document in archicad below
that you also find a free discord link
where you can join a community of
architects architecture students and
many people in the field who are
constantly collaborating and
communicating to be better every single
day so enough of my rant let's keep
going on with this tutorial and zoom in
a little bit next what we're going to do
is come back to our wall tool we're
going to change our wall from wall
external to wall internal and we're
simply going to click a 90 millimeter
stud partition that isn't insulated
because that's just what i'm choosing to
do i don't need my inside walls
insulated at all it looks very very
simple through this picture it basically
looks like we have one wall at the back
and we have a little hallway here so
what i would assume is we would have
something along these lines where we'd
have a bathroom a bedroom and a small
toilet somewhere in this little room now
i'm not going to go into full details of
creating everything we're just going to
keep it very simple bare bones basic so
let's come up to our door tool let's
open up those settings by clicking up
the top or pressing command t
personally everybody knows i hate these
orange lines so let's override
everything and change it to black
now we have a 900 millimeter wide
internal door that we can simply press
ok on and then we can simply drop that
into our project as we see fit
so now we have two internal doors swing
doors swinging the correct way
showcasing what we need to show if we
tap escape then we can actually come
back into our object tool open up the
same settings in the same manner and
let's start by typing in toilet now i
personally have 4d library so i have a
number of objects that you do not have
but we're going to be sticking to the
typical archicad available library here
we have the water closet 26 same
scenario let's make sure that's black
and then we're going to change our
object material and change that to mep
plumbing press ok and let's drop our
toilet into this situation
again selecting our toilet once command
d to drag it back we're allowed to move
that as we see fit obviously this door
is either too large or the room is too
small so let's drop that door size to
800
command d to move it down and we have a
much smaller door that is somewhat
appropriate to our actual toilet size
now if we wanted to know how big that
room is specifically there's a number of
ways we can do it we could tap the m
button on our keyboard for mary to
measure very quickly or tap escape and
come to our dimension tool on the side
then we could simply click on two of our
walls right click ok
and show us the dimensions that we're
actually working with now if we don't
like the size of this toilet let's say
this wall needs to be smaller let's
press command d drag it across
hit where we're measuring from and let's
say we want to make it 900 millimeters
wide instead of having to do the math to
my head and actually calculating what i
need to minus from 1184 down to 900 i
can simply type in 900 and press the
minus key which will do the math for me
284 pressing okay now we have a 900 wide
toilet suite and if i do the same thing
in this scenario here let's say we want
that to be 1600 we can quickly adjust
everything we need to align our toilet
exactly how it needs to be now you see
that we've moved a couple of the walls
and they aren't joined there we can
simply click on one of these edges and
adjust all the way across or if i press
ctrl or command z we can undo that i can
select those two walls command or
control i
for igloo and they will automatically
link together now if we come back into
our object tool let's go to our object
tool let's type in bed and we'll use one
of the archicad 26 beds just as a
standard default drop our bed in command
d to move our bed if we wanted on this
wall we could simply do the command d
move it to where it needs to be if we
want it on our other wall command e for
elephant allows us to rotate click once
hold shift click again command d move it
to the wall we would rather have it on
so personally i believe control z puts
it back to the space i need it to be now
in this scenario you would also need
some sort of bathroom and some sort of
vanity basin shower to actually utilize
this small house and what we can see is
it's too small to fit a good size
bathroom so what i'm going to do is
click once select all of what we have
just created
press command d let's push this up 1500
millimeters and select our three walls
that we've previously created once again
command i control i allows us to quickly
join everything we need and we can
delete those dimensions at the same time
i can turn off my trace reference on the
side here by toggling this on and off if
you do not see this trace reference
simply come across the window at the top
palettes and trace and reference now as
you can see that shower and bathroom
still needs to be created so let's click
on this wall once let's duplicate it by
clicking command d and then tapping the
option button and let's type in 1500
millimeters for the purposes of argument
if i go command i we simply close off
that space and we can include some sort
of bathroom in this space
coming back to our object tool object
settings let's type in shower we can use
the shower cabin 26 in this example once
again make sure you get your layers on
the correct layers this isn't critical
at this stage but it is something that
is good practice and a good habit to
form from day one because you are going
to lose patience and your mind if you
don't get your layers right once you
start documenting all the way through to
construction now let's click ok let's
drop our shower into this new bathroom
that we've created let's press command d
move it to where we need and adjust it
so it is slightly bigger to the full
size of that actual bathroom now
personally i don't like the wall it sits
on i'm going to press command m for mary
click in the middle and mirror that
whole shower once again now all we're
missing in this design is a simple
vanity so once again let's open up our
object tool let's go to vanity and find
ourselves a nice vanity unit it doesn't
have to be an overkill but it really
doesn't matter what it is because you
can fine tune this however you see fit
i'm simply going to select that one for
the time being rotate it with command or
control e adjust it to where i need and
i'm going to make it about 1500
millimeters wide just to provide this
room with a little bit of space now what
you'll see is the room is still quite
tight it is still quite small but at the
end of the day we want to utilize our
space so we can hold our option key and
try and place a door in here but what
you'll see is it's going to clash with
that vanity because we've made this room
quite small so if we open up that door
command t for tom let's type in pocket
door
and what we're going to get is a cavity
slider pocket door now once again
removing that orange straight away
because i absolutely hate it we can
insert our pocket door command m to flip
it to the correct rotation and direction
we need it to go and now instead of
having a swing door that clashes with
our vanity we have a pocket door that
allows us to actually utilize this space
properly last but not least i'm not
going to waste a ton of this space so
what i'm going to simply do is adjust
our vanity basin make it a lot larger
and then i'm going to turn this into a
small little walk-in robe so once again
let's press option on our door swing
swing that in command t option and we're
going to type in opening in this
scenario all we simply need is a simple
door opening to cut that wall open press
ok and we'll see that we've
automatically created an opening in our
door that we can adjust to the right
size
if we come back to our 3d marquee we've
done quite a lot you'll see first of all
that our decking hasn't been adjusted as
our walls did so we'll quickly adjust
the edge of that one to align it to
where it needs to be spinning around we
can see our full 3d model we have our
bathroom our bedroom and we have our
small little walk-in robe so we've
created basically an entire home plate
very quickly without having to do too
many things multiple times over coming
back to our ground floor plan we can
simply model in a small little kitchen
here and then we can model our deck and
our door let's start by modeling some
windows into this space so if we come
across to our window tool open up our
window settings we can start by using a
sliding door a sliding door is what is
showcased in this image and again i have
the 4d options which you will not have
by default but nonetheless we can still
use a typical sliding door now i'm going
to in this instance i'm going to use
this door here as my example i'm going
to again click away that orange because
it is horrendous i'm going to make it to
700 high and for the width i'm actually
going to determine that by placing it
into our object first and then adjusting
as wide as it needs to be now we can
open up those settings again by pressing
command or ctrl t coming down to our
model attributes and then we can change
our framework so let's say this
framework we want it to be wood we want
it to be something like light oak
automatically it changes everything to
light oak we still have our glass as
clear let's press ok come back to our 3d
to see what we've just created and there
we go we have this beautiful wood frame
door already modelled very very quickly
coming back to our ground floor plan we
want to include some actual natural
light into this space so let's open up
our window tool once again let's go to
our sliding door let's type in window
and let's scroll down until we find
window 26 now clicking ok we can drop
one window 26 right here come into our
3d to see what it looks like well first
of all it's too low it's the wrong size
it is almost a sliding door so we come
back into our settings we're going to go
fix glass let's make it one meter by one
meter to make it a simple square and
let's lift that 900 millimeters from the
seal pressing okay automatically it
changes everything that we need and it
is thrown a nice window into our space
that is simply a fixed panel of glass
back to our ground floor plan what i
will do is highlight our entire bathroom
and mirror that design
so that we can actually introduce one
more window in this space if i duplicate
that window along the side select one of
the hotspots and adjust the width of it
to fit between our vanity and our wall
coming back to our 3d
and panning around we can select that
window once again
drag that all the way down
and then look at it from the outside
provides us with a beautiful nice fixed
frame window last but not least we
obviously have our bedroom so we can
easily duplicate this into our bedroom
if we wanted to open out the settings we
can change that to a sliding tilt turn
whatever kind of window we want for the
purposes of this design i'm not going to
worry about changing anything i'm just
simply going to leave the window there
now if we wanted to go ahead and create
a kitchen we could come into our objects
once again and we could start typing in
cabinetry and we have a variety of
kitchen cabinetry islands we can also
type in cupboard to find a variety of
different cupboards that we might be
wanting to use we can also type in
cooktop we can type in rangehood we can
search for what we need including
fridges freezers microwave ovens
whatever we want to do to create that
actual kitchen island bench but now what
i want to focus on is the actual roof
structure and the outside of this
building to make it look quite pretty so
if we press command up we go to our roof
plan here on the side we can right click
our ground floor go show as trace
reference and we'll see what we've
created down below now to create a
simple roof structure let's go to our
roof tool here on the right we want to
select a very simple roof style we don't
want to create a multifaceted hip and
valley roof so we just want to create
one simple roof the pitching point will
be from the outside leaf in this
scenario and then we can go ahead drag
drop click
extend to where we need controller
command m to mirror hold the option or
alt button adjust this secondary roof in
line with the outside wall below and
then to connect these roofs perfectly in
the middle let's select one old command
click on one edge and repeat the same
step to have those roof panes
automatically join now if i select both
of these roof panes we're going to see
that it's 22 degrees that is a very low
pitch for what i'm seeing here so i'm
simply going to type in 45 degrees go to
3d and we are going to see we've very
quickly created our roof now obviously
this roof looks horrible and ugly so we
want to make it look a lot prettier and
we have a huge gap in our entire
building so let's start with the simple
elements ctrl t open up our roof let's
go roof timber frame that is most likely
going to be a 190 millimeter rafter so
we can adjust that next we want to
select all of our external walls so if
we click option g or alt g we can group
the walls that we previously created now
that we have all of our external walls
selected we can press alt g again to
ungroup which is going to allow us to
extend that past the entire roof
if we simply right click anywhere on
this project go down to connect
go
solid element operations we're going to
have a new little pop-up window
automatically we're going to have our
target selected as the walls we're going
to tap escape and select our two roof
panes we're going to hit the operator
adders operator button and move down to
subtract with upwards extrusion and hit
execute what you'll see is a small
little error here basically i did not
align the edge of my roof perfectly with
the edge of my wall which means i was 10
millimeters out if i come back to my
roof pane select that roof adjust that
10 millimeters and then come back into
3d we'll see it automatically trims that
space perfectly to how we need so what
we're now seeing is an almost finished
product but that roof pitch still looks
a little bit too low compared to our
image let's bump that up to 60 degrees
probably a little bit too high 50
degrees might be bang on now we've come
pretty close there's only a few little
finishing touches to go let's start by
selecting the timber walls inside so
this is obviously timber this is timber
and this is also timber if we go to our
command t option settings we can
override everything in this scenario to
make it light oak and press ok our roof
panel also has light oak on the
underside so if we change this to light
oak press ok
we're starting to see the compilation
come together next we want to select our
outside walls to create this black
external cladding now what you're going
to notice is archicad does not have a
default charred black timber look which
means we have to go ahead and do a
little bit of an advanced maneuver to be
able to introduce a new texture into
this project so what we want to do is we
want to escape from that scenario we
want to come up to our window and our
toolbars and then we want to come down
to attributes once again another little
pop-up menu will appear search for a
charred black timber seamless texture
find one that you like the most this
adobe one is actually quite nice so i'm
simply just going to save that to my
downloads and then we're going to open
up our material palette selection so
this is our surface model adjuster and
we're going to create a new surface
texture if we scroll down to wood we
already have a number of wood textures
already created so we want to use them
as our base let's select the pine grain
vertical and select the new button we
want to duplicate it let's just name
this wood black
chard
and click ok
now you're going to see it still looks
identical to what we had before if we
first select the surface color change
that material to a little bit of black
chard and then we're going to find our
actual material we've just saved so
let's go add find that black material
we've just added click ok
wait for that to load and then press ok
once more what we want to do is make
sure that our wood texture that we've
just imported is the same size as the
actual texture otherwise it's going to
look very skewed very warped next we're
going to press ok
and then we're going to select all of
the walls once again that needs to go to
this black material command t open up
our settings type in wood and we'll see
we have our black charred timber we've
created pressing ok you're going to see
it's come in automatically but it's come
in as a horizontal texture so if we open
up that surfaces again rotate that 90 to
0 press ok it'll go to the beautiful
vertical we're looking for
if we then finally select our roof
command t to open up those settings once
more and we override the two remaining
textures to wood black chard pressing
okay closing that setting there we have
our completed 3d architectural model
anyway that's all from me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did and
want to see more great architectural
content especially around archicad make
sure you check out the playlist to the
side of me if you love the video i'd
appreciate it if you smash that
subscribe button down below and like
always i'll see you next monday